influenza viruses can cause some
symptoms similar to the novel
coronavirus including sudden onset of
fever and coughing as anyone who's had
it knows it's more than just a cold for
some it's deadly the World Health
Organization says that annual epidemics
result in about three to five million
cases of severe illness caused by
influenza globally and flu viruses kill
somewhere between 290 thousand and six
hundred fifty thousand people every
single year
those numbers are broad enough but
there's another factor we have very
sketchy information worldwide on how
many people get the flu and don't end up
in the hospital that makes it tough to
nail down exactly how deadly the illness
is a detailed running count kept by the
Centers for Disease Control in the u.s.
shows that this year so far flu viruses
in the country have killed somewhere
around 1 in 2000 people who caught them
children and the elderly are the most
likely to die so even though we've been
dealing with flu for centuries there are
huge gaps and what we know about it
little wonder then that the data on the
novel coronavirus is also very unclear
and changes from day to day the Chinese
government has now said that it's
identified well over 30,000 coronavirus
infections in the country and medics
have confirmed that as of February 7th
over 600 people have died due to the new
virus in theory that means two out of
every hundred people who get the virus
will die of it that's a much higher rate
than flu but that number is attached to
a major uncertainty factor if some
people catch it but only develop mild
symptoms or none at all
they won't be counted so if many more
people have actually caught the virus
but haven't been tested because their
symptoms have been mild estimates of how
lethal it actually is could easily drop
once we know more
numbers for pandemics are hard to
collect which makes mortality rates
difficult to deduce so far the entire
coronavirus epidemic hasn't killed as
many people as on average die from the
ordinary flu in a single day but the
very fact that it's new and we still
know very little about it has
authorities around the world worried one
thing we do know wash your hands
that's one of the best ways to prevent
getting any kind of respiratory virus
let's get more on this from Derrick
Williams from a science desk Oh welcome
at Derrick that's sir it's very salutary
that report there so more people die a
flu every year than from the entire
Coronis correct coronavirus epidemic so
far so every day every day so why aren't
people sort of running out and buying
masks every year to protect them against
flu well I think that boils down to the
fact that we're just kind of used to it
flu is sort of business as usual we've
been living with it for a very very long
time and we can kind of predict when
it's going to happen there's a flu
season in the northern hemisphere there
are also steps that you can take to
prevent flu there are vaccines that have
been developed that can for example
protect some of the people who are most
in danger from fluid the elderly or
children but and there are also
medications in place antivirals for
example like Tamiflu so there are there
are prevention methods that are there we
don't unfortunately none of those
prevention methods work with coronavirus
and as you said despite the come there
prevention methods more people are dying
every day so who does it make sense then
rationally for us to be frightened of
this than the new bug when so many
people so many of us don't think twice
about flu well it boils down to a sort
of this big gray number really it's that
it's the mortality rate right we heard
that it kills two in every hundred
people that contracted that's really a
very uncertain number at this particular
moment because in China they're dealing
with this health crisis right there
they're overrun with thousands of people
who are pretty severely ill they don't
have any
time they don't have the resources to
test people who might for example have
very might have the peptic coronavirus
but have very mild symptoms or even be
asymptomatic have no symptoms at all
and so this this mortality rate this
idea it's killing too and every hundred
people I think that most most
researchers expect that to go down as we
find out more about how many people
actually contract it and what kind of an
impact it would have in this much
problem what's probably a much larger
group of people okay I think those
fingers are important to it and every
one hundred and likely to go down so
let's just keep this this all in
proportion so how do the two coronavirus
and flu how do they compare in terms of
the ease of transmission well contagion
viral epidemiologists they they look at
they look at what's called the basic
reproduction number it's called the are
not now in in terms of of the are not
for flu is 1.3 now what that means is
out of every person who gets flu during
the flu season they'll give it on
average to 1.3 other people which is how
which is how the flu season continues to
be sort of this self-generating thing
during during the cooler months of the
year I read we don't really have that
number yet for the corona virus but I
read a study last week that estimated
that it would be around 2.2 now that if
that was true that would be quite a
worrying number but we don't really have
that information yet we don't really
have enough data to back that up yet
because as we said we don't know how
many people actually have gotten it yet
so the the the only thing that we really
can say for sure is one researcher that
I was reading an article today he said
the one thing that we know for sure is
that this is a beast that's moving very
quickly ok so briefly that are there any
other significant differences between
the way that health professionals are
treating coronavirus and flu well and
they're still hoping I think the w-h-o
is still hoping very much but what they
call containment within China which
means that they're going to be able to
keep it from setting in this this corona
virus from having epicenters in other
countries as long as they can keep it
contained they would have then contained
within the country they can hope that at
some point they're going to be actually
even able to eradicate it like they did
with stars
however it's looking like it's in
enough that that might not happen and so
it could very well be that within the
coming years this ends up being
something that is like other coronavirus
is sort of endemic in the world out
there
Derrick Williams from DW signs thank you